[Musique]
je suis jean luc blanchette j'ai 43 ans
je fais curé de la paroisse saint
françois d'assise à drummondville
jésus accueille toute personne c'est la
première messe de la journée en a trois
on n'a pas idée que j'ai cinq curieux
recul dans les paroisses que je suis
responsable a commencé je veux dans mon
enfance
ça s'appelle l'apparence des gens sont
super saiyan dont on avait un magasin
général le seigneur soit avec vous c'est
en regardant le prêt de la paroisse en
chine j'étais vraiment fasciné par les
gestes que faisait le charisme il le
donne à ses ennemis en leur disant
prenez et mangez en tous enfin le genre
à jouer à metz le avec un bus cuir et de
ce jus de pomme l'eau pendant que mes
paraître au magasin
[Musique]
à l'adolescence j'ai commis ce projet
l'autre côté un peu mon jeu n'est pas
être ridiculisé avec mes copains avec
qui on t et coll
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
à la fin du cégep ou le feu lui que je
m'inscrive à l'université avaient
l'option la théologie au grand séminaire
devenir prêtre et l'option d'aller en
éducation de mes professeurs aux
primaires indique si jamais je me rends
compte que c'est pas ma place va ce
moment à l'heure toujours possible de
changer plan de carrière commencer une
vie de couple avec quelqu'un plus
vouloir fonder une famille j'ai la
chance d'avoir de très bons amis par
exemple qui me permettent aussi de vivre
un certain vécu de famille mais c'est
sûr qu'il ya des journées où parfois on
ne peut être porté à envier à d'autres
villes mr jourdain ce que je serais prêt
à mettre de côté tout ce que je suis
comme prêtre puis à l'intérieur samedi
toujours non confirmée mais ça me
redonne encore un petit boost pour
continuer mais on savait que tout le
vécu d'église est en mutation du helmand
est en changement des chamboulements
majeur avec le langage de liz était
injuste et bien vide aujourd'hui c'est
vrai comment ces grandes valeurs lors
qu'on porte la vision de lévis que la
nôtre semaine se soigner avec les bons
l'avortement elle et des mariages aux
gens de même sexe ne se taira cet amour
là c'est dans le concret c'est dans ce
qu'on vit à tout moment pierre chaque
instant avec le conseil de pédophilie
bon d autres josé but quand on connaît
actuellement
ça m'interpelle beaucoup c'est vrai je
me dis si je suis capable d'être proche
des gens de témoigner de ce que je suis
tout simplement dans mon quotidien je
pensais même comme un certain
contrepoids ce qui ce qui me touche ce
qui me fait le plus mal gérées dans ces
circonstances là c'est d'abord la
généralisation qu'ils en font
à
en ceci que je trouve extraordinaire
dans mon véhicule prime la proximité
avec les gens quand les gens sont
capables de le dire dans une telle
difficulté qui très vert dans un grand
moment de joie qu'ils vivent 20 c'est
tellement beau ma vie où les forces
intérieures que j'ai c'est tellement
plus grand que nature bas à mon sens de
sa vie un dieu
cet argent est encore très actif pour
moi piste encore encore ce que je dois
faire dans ma vie
[Musique]